let me jump to this next story we'll
kind of bring all of this foreign policy
stuff back home because we have this
report from the daily mail
joint chiefs send memo to all u.s troops
condemning
maga riots as sedition after arrest of
current
and retired officers and spell out that
they only follow lawful orders in fresh
warning to trump
they say the military's top leaders
issued a written reminder to all service
members tuesday
that the deadly insurrection at the
capitol was a criminal act the memo
signed by all members of the joint
chiefs of staff
also reminded military members that joe
biden was duly elected as the next
president
it comes after the arrest of current and
retired
officers among the riders among the
known retired veterans who stormed the
capitol was ashley babbitt
a retired air force veteran who was shot
dead retired lieutenant colonel larry
lieutenant colonel larry renville brock
junior 53
was slapped with federal charges after
he was pictured carrying plastic
handcuffs
in the capitol during the riot the army
is also investigating a psychological
warfare officer
captain emily rainey for leading a group
of people from north carolina to the
rally
so this i found interesting that it
turns out even the uh the horned viking
guy
navy veteran yeah there were a lot of
people there who served
and you've also got the oath keepers
many of them who have served many of
them who are still
police officers now clearly support the
president
and i guess the question is
does the like the military
overwhelmingly support the president
would they support him
you know moving forward well that's
that's the big fear i mean i'm literally
just as as you're reading that i'm
thinking of the um you know the the
smedley butler
yeah yeah that plot i mean you know who
they were going to use for that
was all the these veterans from world
war one i mean that's who that because
if you if you
actually wanted like what would your big
fear be if you were the establishment
and that that would be your fear so you
better get that under control
yeah and that fear is real because why
else would they be sending out a memo to
all the branches of
the military that's the point you know
you know why are they doing this if
they're not worried about something
or other branches of the military uh
potentially
deciding or thinking about doing
something well when when those polls
came out
before the election saying that the
military overwhelmingly supported joe
biden
i just didn't believe it i laughed i was
like come on
why would first of all i i i've not
served um my family has most most of
them
and my family have in some way been
involved in you know the armed forces
but i did live briefly on a military
base i do know many people so i don't
want to speak for them
but i kind of feel like the amount of
respect they'd have for someone like
biden who is a career politician
enriched himself off the office and
votes for the wars that gets
you know them sent out i don't think
they're going to be like that's the guy
i pick
and and not only that you look at what
trump says about the troops what he does
for them
and how he advocates for them and i just
feel like it makes no sense
so i asked some people you know do you
think because there was a
statement put out in the washington post
by all uh former defense secretaries
warning members of the military not to
follow trump's orders
they were like do not well it was it was
interesting because this is uh it's
getting close to a military coup when
you have these individuals
telling the military not to obey trump
if he gives them orders to do something
but they wouldn't like you were just
saying they wouldn't need to put that
statement down in the washington post
all former living ex-secretaries of
defense saying don't do this
you will go to prison this is for you to
chris miller of the pentagon
now you have this statement where
they're saying to all the members of the
military it was it was a riot
know it joe biden's president it's done
why are they saying it now that's kind
of freaky
yeah why do they need to say it well
they're definitely concerned
i mean this was one of the big things
about donald trump in general that
really
like scared the establishment and i
think this is the reason why he scares
them a lot more than bernie sanders does
even though bernie sanders did scare
them
is that donald trump's supporters are
just
way tougher like if you had to fist
fight
a random bernie sanders fan or a random
donald trump fan
you would not for a second like i mean
let's just be real people here you would
immediately go i'll take on three bernie
sanders fans if i have to fight them
rather than one donald trump because
donald trump probably has some barrel
chested minor
or something like that he's gonna pound
you into a bloody mess
and bernie sanders is like some gender
studies major hold on but
one other point that i wanted to make to
your kind of question another thing that
is really relevant here is that
joe biden is one of the first presidents
that didn't really address the war
question
at all yeah he's not anti-war a lot of
people know this
a lot of foreign policy experts are
saying he's most likely going to start
more conflicts
and he's going to have the continued
american foreign policy that was just
halfway under donald trump also during
the blm riots he took the side of blm
rather than police officers so a lot of
people serving
in law enforcement in in the military
know that he's on the side of the
of the radishes he's entering joe budden
is entering the presidency with probably
the least amount of confidence from our
men and women in uniform and law
enforcement right now
well the few people that we talked to
that voted for him all regret voting for
him
you know there's other thought thinkers
like naomi wolf that are like why did i
vote for him i was thinkers
i thought uh thought leaders sorry yeah
i'm dyslexic i'm polish i got hit in the
head a lot when i was a kid
so naomi wolf that was funny yeah that
was what did you say if i had known that
joe biden was in favor of lockdowns i
never would have voted for him
and it's like he's he says it all the
time could have known that geez
yeah that's kind of inexcusable to nada
to not know that
but you're right and it's also just that
look joe biden
just basically limped i mean
out of the primaries i mean just kind of
survived them
and was basically um he he almost won it
by process of elimination
like the establishment basically trotted
out all these different people
they were like hey everybody get excited
about warren get excited about bootage
get excited about uh you know who have
kamala harris and none of them
caught fire and then bernie sanders was
doing for and they were terrified of him
so they were like he's no deal and then
they they threw bloomberg out there who
just completely fell apart in the
debates
and then they were like okay i guess all
we have left is biden they had the
coordinated hit
where all of biden's competition dropped
out sanders competition and warren
stayed in
they got him over the finish line and
then he basically ran on being
not trump not campaigning well like
nothing we've ever seen before didn't
run
well right yeah he hid in his basement
and he said i'll just stay away from
this
and and look and that is to some degree
it's like the quality about trump that
got him to the dance is also the thing
that got him out of the dance is that he
does have this personality
that he was willing to say every nasty
thing to everyone
around in order to really beat them but
that also turned a lot of people off so
it was like a double-edged sword
and it was enough for biden biden's like
the press will carry me that social
media came down and silenced you know
the big hunter biden story the big
october surprise basically got squashed
and that got him over there but we've
never really had a president like that
not in my lifetime
who won that way obama inspired his way
into the white house you know i mean it
trump inspired his way into the white
house
this guy was in there with the help of
social media tech oligarchs and the
mainstream media overlords that are like
hey
you're going to represent us you're
going to work for us he's like
he's not even saying yes he's like good
where he's in they're like
joe can we count on you to do as you're
told
come on man i've been doing as i told
for 47 years uh-huh just tell me what to
do i'll go to sleep in the corner and
you
write my name for me that's essentially
what's going to happen especially when
you see the special interest
the corporatists the banks uh the the
complexes behind them that are
essentially going to be setting american
policy
fast forward in in a way that we have
never seen lobbyists
take control of our government he's a
huge lobbyist he even argued with barack
obama about the power of lobbyists and
how great they are and how we need more
of them
barack obama even ignored even argued
with them against that let's jump to
this story
real quick from the daily mail four
thousand armed patriots plan to surround
congress to stop
trump impeachment law enforcement
reveals at closed-door briefing they say
rep conor lamb revealed tuesday
law enforcement briefed lawmakers on a 4
000 person group of armed patriots
prepared
to prevent democrats from entering the
capital as they move to impeach donald
trump
the threats we are facing are very
specific lamb said tuesday
is more national guard are deployed to
dc they have published rules of
engagement
meaning when you shoot and when you
don't shoot this is an organized group
that has a plan
in their minds they are patriots so this
this is how we
so this is now a contest of wills trump
declared a state of emergency monday
night
that allows the department of homeland
security and federal emergency emergency
management
agency to coordinate with local
authorities on monday night new chiefs
of capital police told house democrats
they were looking into three separate
plans to hold protests including one
described as
largest armed protest ever to take place
on american soil
but the most concerning is said to
involve armed riders encircling the
capital and blocking democrats from
entering
killing if necessary so that republicans
are able to take command of government
i i don't believe it yeah i mean i mean
i mean maybe but let me put it this way
you mean to tell me that there's a large
group of people
defending trump defying trump that i
don't quite understand
i have i've listened to what the trump
supporters have said
and they are repeatedly saying trump
never said storm the capital
trump was still speaking at the event
when they already started breaching the
barricades
and then trump said we will p we said
we're going to peacefully march and then
cheer on politicians
that was already going down at the
capitol while trump was speaking
so i wonder if the people who were there
probably a lot of them were trump
supporters
but there are elements of the right that
don't much care for trump
they may be you know i'll put it this
way there are people who are trump
supporters first
trump says go home and in peace trump
probably could have issued stronger
statements but trump says we condemn the
violence you know go there peacefully
cheer on protesters there are people who
listened
you have this captain uh emily i believe
her name is emily rainey
who's being investigated we just
mentioned her and she said she went
there to hear trump speak and then they
all got in their buses and left
there there was that musician uh i was
named ariel pink who said i went to hear
him speak and then i went to
went to my hotel went to sleep these are
the people who like trump who listen to
him
and when trump says you know go in peace
they do
but then there are other people who are
not trump supporters first they're
something else so they go to the capitol
they engage in this
i have to wonder now when when they're
saying they want to help republicans
take control of government who are these
people that are willing to put
themselves on the line for mitch
mcconnell
i don't i don't buy that yeah it seems
very hard uh
it seems very hard to believe i mean i
suppose it's not impossible
i it doesn't seem likely to me there
there seems to be no
there's no strategy there there's no way
this could possibly work
i also do think that they are really
trying to
like they're one of the things that the
establishment are experts at
is exploiting a crisis like they're so
when this thing with the capital
building happens
there you can see their eyes get wide
like okay
now we jump on this and now what they're
using is this argument
which is what the articles of
impeachment were you know
going to be that he incited in
insurrection that he's inciting violence
now
certainly you can say that donald trump
by claiming the election was stolen got
a lot of people very worked up
and maybe that that made them more
willing to do something than they would
be
but you could also say that framing the
the president
uh for uh as a guilty of treason and a
russian asset
that that would incite some violence you
could certainly say that some of the
people on the left who have basically
been saying for years now that uh cops
are out there
hunting black people for sport and i'm
no fan of the cops but it's obviously
just
a lie and that that definitely incited a
lot of violence obviously maxine waters
but they only want to apply trump the
double standard i'm just
i gotta be honest it's like every day i
see something about the media the lies
the double standards and i'm just like
i think we all know and anybody anybody
who's saying otherwise is lying
they're just you're flying so listen i
think it's possible that there's a large
group of people that are angry
but i think these are it's the
equivalent of the people who voted
against trump
there are angry people who probably
don't care about trump and are against
biden
so it's it's entirely possible there's a
large group of people who have crazy
plans
and i don't know where this is coming
from there's reports of like armed
capital protests and like a a
inauguration protest
i've not seen those things i've only
seen trump supporters denounce or deny
them or warn people not to do it yeah
but i'll say regardless
you know people should not be going on
going down to dc i think the
inauguration
the what that what they're planning is
it seems
a tad bit reckless but i definitely
think they need to up security to an
extreme degree
i mean the last in dc for the time being
the last thing we need is any kind of
escalation
it's the worst possible thing it's going
to result in nothing but bloodshed if
they were to do something like that and
it will
it will serve the opposite of what your
interest is if you
hate this like kind of government
authoritarian control
yes this would be the best thing for
them you can do you cannot win
a show of force with the federal
government don't kid yourself into
thinking
you will if you ever got to the point
where it actually threatened them in
some way they will go
waco style on you and burn children
alive to protect their interests don't
do it do not the way to fight the
federal government
has to be done through peaceful means
right now it's the most militarized
government in human history you want to
do something
if you're in like a red district in in a
rural red
area start teaching prayer in school
again
that way do something like that not even
about that it's about
we've mentioned it several times we're
in the information warfare era where the
information age
winning influence comes through
confident arguments and
playing the game strategically a lot of
these trump supporters like talk about
4d chess
well i think y'all should be playing it
right now because
look at what they're already doing
because some people
stormed to the capitol now that's crazy
the zip tie guys some of this stuff's
crazy should not have been done
but compare that to the the waves of
damage and destruction we've seen
throughout the
last year with black lives matter okay
now to act like
you know aoc goes on uh what you go on
abc saying half of congress is on the
verge of being killed or whatever
and it's like oh calm down calm down but
you can see how they weaponize it
yeah it was it was one of the dumbest
things people could have done well you
can't you can't copy the the techniques
of
the left because they essentially have
the mainstream media
social media and a lot of the larger
kind of cultural sports
spokespeople that that essentially send
out these larger ideas that kind of
justified
lydia sent us a video before about what
happened to
rand paul recently where he was walking
through a crowd and blm protesters
surrounded him
and uh you know with his wife with his
wife
in a very tense situation but there was
no outrage by the mainstream media
they were screaming at him about briana
taylor exactly he
sponsored the bill for brian taylor
exactly so there's always something
so we got to understand there's crazy
and there's bad actors in every group
like we understand yeah but the kind of
thing that i'm worried about and if i
could be allowed to speculate i don't
like to speculate but we know if we let
politicians gain more power from
emergencies
what's stopping them from creating
emergencies to gain more power
and with everything coming up forward i
have this kind of
feeling that there might potentially be
either another
grave escalation that could be planned
and organized or maybe even a false flag
but this is just something that i
personally feel
that we should keep an eye out for
because i think there is a huge
potential
to turn this already horrible situation
to to turn it
all i think a lot worse than it is i
think talk of false flags
is just going to help them more if if
it's true that they want the emergency
then they will love to hear you claiming
that they were the ones who are behind
it so they can say now you're crazy
and these people are crazy no look there
are crazy people
and i i've seen people post crazy stuff
online i have heard
crazy stuff from some of the craziest
you know trump supporting
there are some stories out there reuters
at a store where they interviewed a guy
who said
just if trump just says the word no no
no we don't want any of that trump's
word was go in peace and he condemned
the violence
yeah the strategy now is it's
propagandistic
it's persuasion it's culture it's
influence the daily wire put out this
movie
that's what conservatives need to be
doing that's the battlefield right now
the hearts and minds of the people
i'm not reporting not going and trying
to fight like you said the most
militarized government
what we need to do is try to de-escalate
some of the crazies
agree the bad actors and you don't
de-escalate
by shunning them and attacking them and
putting them in a corner where they get
to grow and fester
and and not have their bad ideas
challenged so whether it's bad actors or
radicals on the left
or right we have to understand that this
area of censorship you're
essentially creating more radicals and
more people on the floor absolutely
right about that and this is what always
happens like even on an individual level
right like psychologically speaking it's
like repression and then it comes back
out in some worse form that's why you
don't want to repress
you know like negative feelings thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you